[Applaudissements]
françois bayrou applaudi alors qu'il
s'apprête à créer son nouveau parti le
modem mais depuis quel bilan pour le
parti centriste
on en train de nourrir un nouvel espoir
politique tout part de là en 2007
premier tour de la présidentielle le
candidat de l'udf françois bayrou est
troisième avec 18 57% des voix et se
sent pousser des ailes pour changer
définitivement la politique française
j'annonce la création d'un nouveau parti
politique le parti démocrate le parti
démocrate qui s'appellera finalement
mouvement démocrate - à droite que l'udf
créé par giscard
sauf que au centre-droit ils ne sont pas
tous prêts à le suivre
je pense qu'effectivement il fait une
très grave erreur stratégique et qu'il
la paiera à court terme mais je forme
pour lui comme on dit des voeux de
prompt rétablissement
si on au centre donc mais pas de quoi
faire reculer le jeune parti les
législatives 2007 arrive
les militaires sont gonflés à bloc mes
chers mais ferme d'année et enfin le
vote test le premier tour des
législatives le 10 juin 2007 le modem de
françois bayrou on est bien loin des 18
% de la présidentielle le nouveau parti
centriste n'obtiendra qu'un à quatre
députés
trois députés finalement pour le modem
c'est un premier échec le premier d'une
longue série
en 2008 bayrou n'arrive pas à décrocher
la mairie de pau la faillite
fiasco aussi aux européennes de 2009
8,45 % des voix derrière le ps l'ump et
europe ecologie les verts j'ai pensé que
l'on ne pouvait pas séparer les enjeux
nationaux et les enjeux européens je
n'ai pas réussi à faire partager ce
sentiment
et c'est pire aux régionales de 2010
aucune victoire
c'est un résultat catastrophique pour le
modèle sans compter les 9,13 % la
présidentielle de 2012 et les seuls deux
sièges aux législatives la même année
pour se relancer le modem doit attendre
2017 avec le soutien à emmanuel macron
je vais tout faire et des maquereaux et
élus bayrou est nommée garde des sceaux
sylvie goulard aux armées et marielle de
sarnez aux affaires européennes
enfin l'état de grâce n'a pas duré un
mois et deux jours seulement la sphère
des emplois présumés fictifs modem les a
tous poussé à la démission
je choisis de ne pas exposer à des
campagnes mensongères le gouvernement et
le président de la république que je
soutiens malgré tout le modem reste bien
ancré dans la vie politique avec deux
membres au gouvernement et 47 députés du
jamais vu en revanche du côté des
adhérents pas de quoi se réjouir
ils étaient douze mille en 2010 est cinq
fois moins qu'en 2007
[Musique]